welcome back we are going to hear from
some uh
viewers and listeners via discord
momentarily at davidpakman.com
discord uh you can of course get a
david pakman show membership which gives
you early access to full episodes of the
show so you can hear
live calls or avoid them depending on
your preference
much earlier than anybody else all right
very very exciting stuff
davidpakman.com discord is the place to
get in touch
with me why don't we go first today
let's try something different let's go
to
johanna in chile johanna you're on the
air
hello hello how are you yes please mute
discord because we're hearing the blings
uh i don't know how to do that actually
all right well what's on your mind today
um uh well uh as you see i'm from chile
i know you are close to me in terms of
argentina yes greetings
well i have a question slash comment uh
is what did you expect from right-wing
media
asking those all those gotcha questions
to either gents like you or other
uh members of the cabinet of joe biden
sorry you said asking all of those what
questions what was the word
uh this gotcha questions oh oh gotcha
questions yeah
i think that they're trying to so here's
what's going on johanna there's a couple
things going on
one it's fox news so they want to play
gotcha with democrats that's what they
do
but especially because biden just hasn't
really had
any cartoonish big scandalous missteps
they're trying to create them they're
trying to create drama where let's face
it
joe biden's administration has been
boring in the sense that he promised to
do vaccines and we're doing three
million vaccines a day
he said that he would do stimulus and he
got it done he's just working on stuff
so they're trying to create
drama where there's very little drama
oh so but i think uh dan saki
yeah i don't know well uh
is doing a terrific job she's doing a
good job i think that she's been
underprepared on some of the immigration
questions where she seems
she has some talking points in front of
her but she doesn't really deliver them
in a coherent way
i think she could be better on
immigration but otherwise i think she's
doing a very good job yeah
okay thanks all right thank you johanna
from chile great to hear from you